comme vous venez de déguster qu'on va
parler devant mais que ça va peut-être
donner soif jeu juste vérifier comme
vous avez déjà eu quelques verres vous
soyez encore réveillé donc vous allez
devoir faire quelque chose très simple
pour moi c'est la même chose que pour
faire santé qu'est un grand geste pour
lever la main ainsi vous si vous pensez
que l'être humain la vigne et le vin
dans compte ils ont un destin commun je
vis très bien
en tout cas on va explorer tout ça
aujourd'hui mais ils ont en tout cas un
passé et un présent depuis des siècles
des millénaires voir la nuit des temps
le vin la vigne et l'être humain sont
très intrinsèquement liés commençons par
jésus-christ qui en partant de rien
fit apparaître du vent ensuite l'église
trans encore utilisent le jus de raisin
fermenté le vin pour symboliser le corps
du christ
si on fait un petit ce transfert dans le
temps alexandre dumas disait que le vent
c'est vraiment la partie intellectuelle
d'un repas est de nos jours en tout cas
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le vent
c'est certainement un des meilleurs
lubrifiant social qu'il soit si on
poursuit si on reprend que sérieusement
chez les nos amis les grecs et à
quelques temps aristote platon eu ce
fascinait pour ce breuvage
il buvait gardot tout l'intérêt t sur le
vend car il trouvait fantastique que
simplement avec un fruit
on arrive à faire un breuvage qui
rendent le foriic ivre et qui parfois
consommés en excès puisse conduire à des
débords puisse toujours le cas
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pas fait de
progrès à ce niveau là mais surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est que sans
l'homme en fait la vigne ne produirait
même pas de raison donc pas devin donc
il ya forcément une sorte de lien ce que
je vous propose aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
fasse une sorte d'analogie entre la vie
du vent la vie de la vigne jusqu'à un
vent et ensuite jusqu'à en parallèle
avec la vie de l'homme et vous allez
voir que peut-être non seulement c'est
une plante qui a toujours été proche de
l'homme dans sa vie mais que sûrement on
a aussi des choses à apprendre de la
vigne
commençons par le tout ait pu la
conception un homme une femme
c'est ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir faire
vous faire naître et que vous soyez
aujourd'hui devant moi par contre il ya
quand même deux trois recommandations
il ya certains aliments qui sont
proscrits on demande aussi à la femme
généralement qui porte le bébé
puisqu'elle va lui donner c'est un peu
son alimentation quelque part de pas
fumer ne pas consommer d'alcool et de
faire un petit peu attention puisque
c'est toute la base du futur être humain
qui est qu'elle va nourrir pendant neuf
mois la vigne c'est un petit peu
similaire il faut déjà un terrain qui
soit propice adéquat
donc si on prend la vigne déjà on va
avoir ce qu'on appelle le ph donc
l'acidité du sol si c'est trop bas on va
avoir de la solubilité de certains
éléments par exemple la lumière mais ça
va complètement empoisonné la plante
même chose que pour que la fumée pour un
bébé au même titre si le sol est trop
basique on va aussi risqué desclaux rose
ou d'autres problèmes la vie ne va pas
réussir à prendre ces nutriments
on peut aussi avoir des différents
éléments perturbateurs
par exemple les nématodes qui vont
attaquer les racines de la jeune vignes
et donc il faut vraiment planter une
vigne qui soient adéquates donc comme
pour l'homme
il faut vraiment tenir compte des
facteurs préliminaire on va dire déjà
pour pouvoir concevoir le futur grand
bain ensuite vous compare encore l'être
humain et la ville ce là où ça devient
un petit peu intéressants certes on
parle d'une alimentation qui soit
équilibrée pour être en bonne santé
l'homme on recommande les fameux cinq
fruits et légumes par jour
certains et certains autres éléments
nutritifs pour la vigne c'est le soleil
qui joue un rôle très important parce
que les villes les feuilles de la vigne
elles vont réussir à prendre le co2 ce
fameux gaza qui en plus est produit par
toutes les choses pas trop trop bien
qu'on fait tous les jours et du coup un
peu alba elle va aspirer ce gaza
à effet de serre et elle va réussir avec
la lumière du soleil à faire la
photosynthèse et le transformer en
énergie pour ce pour se nourrir elle
même jusque là assez simple si on fut si
on suit ses principes sauf que qui dans
la salle prend des fois des compléments
alimentaires des vitamines des
nutriments pose est battu il n'y a pas
de jugement
vous verrez ok bah c'est là où ça se
corse un petit peu et l'homme et la
vigne on peut tomber dans un cercle
vertueux soit vicieux vous donner deux
exemples avec la vigne le premier c'est
vraiment les engrais le deuxième c'est
les herbicides les engrais de synthèse
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
assez dangereux on croit que ça nous
rend service ça donne des éléments
nutritifs à la ville par l'ajout de
produits qui sont un peu de synthèse
mais qui ont les nutriments dont on a
besoin que ce soit là zot ou autre sauf
que quand on fait ça on va avoir plus de
vigueur donc plus de feuilles et donc on
pourrissent d'avoir aussi plus de
maladies donc on va utiliser plus de
traitements pour pouvoir pallier à ces
maladies donc c'est déjà pas très pas
top
dans un autre sens on va utiliser les
herbicides pour être sûr que notre vigne
on soit sympa avec elle et qu'on lui
donne tous les éléments nutritifs dont
elle a besoin et que ses racines puis
spip y puiser sa dans le sol donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est que on va enlever
toutes les herbes qui lui font
concurrence avec les herbicides
je pense que vous avez tous entendu
parler du fameux glyphosate en utilise
le glyphosate ça élimine tout et on
laisse toute la place pour la vigne le
problème c'est que ça élimine aussi ça
dessus tout la vie des sols tous les
micro-organismes et donc les seuls se
retrouvent compactés et on n'arrive plus
à le seul arrive plus à respirer les
vers de terre meurt on n'arrive plus à
avoir l'eau ne peut plus être stocké
dans les sols parce qu'il ya plus de
place les seules sont compactés on a de
l'érosion et du coup qu'est ce qui se
passe
du coup on a besoin de mettre de
l'irrigation parce que l'eau on a qu'ils
tombent naturellement on n'arrive pas à
la garder et de et du coup qu'est ce
qu'on fait on à la vigne qui prend les
nutriments qui puisent les nutriments
grâce à l'eau elle va elle elle est
complètement bloquée donc rohmer des
engrais de synthèse et ainsi de suite
ce qui est un petit peu dommage parce
qu'en finale au final on n'a pas besoin
de ça john exemple chez nous ce qu'on
fait
c'est que entre nos rangs devine on
plante du trèfle rouge sur les blancs
parce qu'ils manquent les raisins blancs
manque d'azoté et sinon on a moins de
potentiel aromatique dont compos mais ce
trèfle rouge entre les rangs ok c'est un
peu plus de job certes mais l' avantage
de ça c'est qu'en fait on va avoir une
solution naturelle qui va permettre de
donner les nutriments dont on a besoin
et se libérer de ses produits de
synthèse et ensuite
l'autre chose qui est génial avec cet
azote qui est créée par le trèfle qui va
être assimilée c'est que le trèfle
pousse pas en même temps que la vigne
donc il prend l'eau quand la ville n'en
a pas besoin
quand il y en a un peu trop donc ça a
fait ponge et ensuite il sèche quand la
vigne a besoin d'eau donc ça fait un
effet de paillage donc sa garde
l'humidité donc c'est absolument tout
bénef de a à z avec une seule solution
et en utilisant les ressources de la
planète qu'on a juste autour de nous
c'est souvent cas ce que moi avec
l'homme c'est que justement l'être
humain des fois on entend on prend un
somnifère
après on est fatigué dont on comprend
qu'il en prend un peu des vitamines ou
des choses pour un buzz booster puis du
coup comme on est tellement fatigués on
un peu d'âme donc on prend des
antidépresseurs et ainsi de suite
alors qu'en soit il ya des solutions
aussi simple dans notre vie prenons le
cas de la vitamine c voulait de la
vitamine c très bien
au lieu de prendre une petite capsule
homme a dilué dans de l'eau prenez
simplement jus de citron dans de l'eau
tiède le matin un bain et ça vous allez
avoir l'effet détoxifiant de votre corps
antioxydants de du jus de citron de la
vitamine c et en plus de ça vous à les
assimiler naturellement d'une source
naturelle tout la vitamine c donc tout
bénef donc des fois on de voir un peu
plus être logique avec ce qu'on fait à
la vigne au lieu de pourrir entre
guillemets les sols à terne et aussi
dans nos vies personnelles puisque il ya
des solutions tout à fait naturel autour
de nous qu'on oublie un petit peu trop
souvent malheureusement continuons avec
d'autres réactions pour l'as pour notre
survie
on a une hormone qui peut être sécrétée
qui et l'adrénaline
si un lion vous courent après que vous
risquez de mourir l'adrénaline savent au
fil d'un petit coup de boost aussi on a
plutôt ça dans notre vie plutôt de pas
face aux examens un petit coup
d'adrénaline ça peut vous booster et
vous allez même surperformé
par contre si vous êtes tout le temps
tout le temps en train de vous essayez
de vous sur expo
arrêtez de vous donner à fond et que
vous vous auto épuisé ça peut pas durer
à long terme et c'est aussi soudé c'est
souvent une des causes que qui
conduisent les gens à des burnout au
niveau du raisin de nouveau très
similaire puisque en fait comme je
disais à leur aisance en l'homme labine
sans l'homme n'y a pas de raison
la vigne c'est une liane tout ce qu'elle
veut c'est monter grimper et se
développer elle s'en fout complètement
de faire des raisons en saas est une
pure c'est la seule chose c'est nous qui
lui faisons faire ça en fait
leur aisance et sa stratégie à elle pour
essayer de survivre parce que si on a
plus si elle voit qu'elle a des
conditions difficiles pas beaucoup de
nutriments peu de soleil et aux autres
elle va dire mon dieu je risque de
mourir il faut que je me protège donc je
vais faire des graines pour être sûr que
quand ça ira mieux je pourrai refaire
d'autres villes donc elle fait les
scellés s'égrènent c'est les fameux
pépin dans vos raisons et ce tous et
elle se dit ok maintenant il faut que ce
soit attractif pour pour pour qu'elles
soient disséminées donc elle fait la
chair qui est sucré juteuse et l entoure
sa d'une coque de protection la peau et
qui quand une fois que ces murs pour
avertir les oiseaux que ses enfants bon
hop ça devient rouge
et comme ça ils peuvent venir la manger
quand le pépin est prêt à pouvoir germé
et ça lui permet de se protéger
donc de nouveau façon très naturelle
pour la vigne et le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a beau qu'à cause du
réchauffement climatique
on a beaucoup de canicule on a bien vu
cet été du coup on se retrouve avec des
problématiques où il fait tellement
chaud que la lave income l'excès
d'adrénaline qui ferait en burn out
elle se bloque complètement elle fait
même pas mûrir les ans donc on n'a même
pas de raison correct pour faire du vent
donc de nouveau tout est question chez
l'homme et pour la vigne déquilibre est
un petit peu de modération
continuons avec ce cycle de vie très
parallèle un bébé un peu c'est toujours
très sensibles aux maladies faut faire
attention et la jeune vie n'est pareil
est là elle fait son réseau racinaire
donc elle elle peut elle va vraiment
être très sensibles à la sécheresse
faudra bien en prendre soin alors qu
ensuite quand on devient adulte on a on
peut faire une carrière on a appris à se
modérer
lavigne aussi elle produit enfin des
raisons et elle va donner des raisins
aussi qu'ils sont enfin de qualité et
après on passe à l'âge
un peu plus élevé ou là on va pas
pénaliser les personnes âgées au
contraire une personne âgée est là toute
l'expérience tout le savoir faire toute
la connaissance qu'elle a accumulées
pendant sa vie donc elle a peut-être pas
la même énergie par contre elle peut
partager beaucoup avec vous et la
vieille vigne c'est un petit peu la même
chose
elle a des vignes des racines très
profondes qui sont structurées et du
coup elle va se produire peut-être moins
de raisons mais des raisins concentré et
de très haute qualité
beaucoup de similarités à nouveau bon
prenons les aléas de la vie
l'homme peut tomber malade si l'on tombe
malade si vous cracher du sang bien sûr
il faudra prendre des antibiotiques
ce que j'aimerais vous dire ce soir
c'est que on peut essayer de prévenir
toujours tout donc il faut réfléchir si
avant de tomber malade pour ne pas
tomber malade ou fait justement du sport
ou cas wanda vous sentez une angine
venir vous pouvez prendre un peu de
gingembre avec du miel dans de l'eau
chaude c'est des solutions qui sont bien
de faire de la prévention
pareil pour la vigne on peut la pallice
et pour la protéger du vent la taille
est plus tard pour éviter le gel pur et
si on a des pressions de maladie prenons
la mouche suzuki- qui attaque en ce
moment beaucoup mes confrères sur fui
qu'est-ce qu'ils font tous ces vignerons
qui beaucoup sont en bio il ne peut pas
ne peuvent même pas utiliser ces
produits chimiques
ils vont utiliser dacca au lean une
argile qui va faire une poudre blanche
sur les raisons et 7,7 caroline c'est
vraiment une solution naturelle pour
empêcher la suzuki- devenir pourquoi
n'at il a réponse avant c'est que le
raisin devient tout blanc et du coup bas
comme l'oiseau qui pensent que qui
attend la mer rouge
la suzuki n zi but c'est pas encore bon
il est pas encore mûr donc je viens pas
donc c'est de nouveau une façon très
simple de juste réfléchir en amont et
avec de la prévention ne plus avoir
besoin d'utiliser des produits chimiques
dangereux après la viticulture on passe
un petit peu à la cave ou une fois qu'on
a le raisin chez nous on peut le suivre
un petit peu donc soit on rajoute des
levures un sélectionné pour avorter à
l'arôme et que tout se passe bien selon
les températures est ce qu'on veut faire
ou on peut laisser un peu moins de
cadres ont raison et on va laisser faire
les levures indigènes qui sont
naturellement présentes sur la peau du
raisin faire leur job
donc ça c'est un peu plus risqué mais si
ça marche ça se passe très bien
par contre il ya des bugs mais méchante
levure celle que vous voyez
rires moi qui peuvent attaquer et faire
que le vent des déviants du coup c'est
pour ça qu'on utilise les fameuses
sulfites
il y en a souvent on l'écran pour ce
tout ce que ça donne mal à la tête mais
il y en a souvent plus dans une fondue
et des fruits secs que dans dieu que
dans une bouteille devant donc c'est
plutôt l'excès de bouteilles de vin qui
cause votre mal de tête du cou un petit
peu de sulfite un antioxydant un
antibactérien et ça permet vraiment de
justement enlevé d'empêcher ces
déviations microbiologique
plutôt que de ne pas en utiliser du tout
est risqué que votre vente ou le travail
de plus d'une année soit gâchée et que
votre client qui valent bord n'apprécie
pas sa bouteille donc de nouveau tout
est une question de modération
au même titre qu'un homme avec
l'éducation vous allez pas laisser faire
votre enfant n'importe quoi par contre
vous parce que sinon il risque de finir
en prison
un peu dommage par contre il faut pas
non plus trop le cadre et parce que
sinon il va plutôt avoir tendance à
vouloir aller chercher plus loin et être
tenté par faire des bêtises donc
toujours un petit peu une question de
modération
et si on va on passe un peu plus à l'âge
adulte maintenant que ce soit pour le
vent presque dans la bouteille et et
vous êtres humains c'est l'éducation
l'art vraiment ce pour vous montrer
qu'il n'y a pas de juste ou de faux il
ya des gens qui sont absolument brillant
qui sont pas du tout aller à
l'université et qui sont des
entrepreneurs merveilleux par contre en
tant qu'être humain c'est pas une
question d'études mais on peut toujours
chercher à s'améliorer approfondir nos
connaissances se développer soi-même et
ça c'est à tous les niveaux pas
forcément avec l'université mais c'est
ça qui va nous donner plus de
connaissances plus de d'expérience aussi
sur la vie et ainsi de suite
un vent c'est la même chose on peut
simplement le vinifier en inox un
chardonnay qui va très bon très
aromatique parfumé et sur le fruit ou on
peut lui donner encore plus de matière
que ce soit plus long en bouche qui soit
plus complexe est structuré en l'élevant
dans une barrique ou dans une amphore
après ces deux chardonnay peuvent être
absolument excellent les deux c'est pas
juste ou faux au même titre que c'est
pas une question de vos études qui vont
prouver qui vous êtes mais c'est
toujours tout une question de choix est
souvent un vigneron
quand il fait un vent on retrouve
vraiment ses valeurs et ses convictions
et aujourd'hui on a un petit peu une
situation où nous on peut faire plein de
choix
et que ce soit sur nos valeurs sur notre
philosophie sur les comment se
comportent entre guillemets et ça va pas
faire qu'on va être une meilleure
personne ou une autre mais ça va faire
ça va définir vraiment qui on est dans
le futur et aujourd'hui le destin commun
qu'on a pour la vigne et le vin c'est
que si on continue vraiment dans cette
lignée il y aura plus de il y aura il y
aura plus tout court de vigne il y aura
plus de vent du tout donc après ce côté
agréable social on le perdra
complètement donc un os de réfléchir un
petit peu comme on veut la diversité de
tous les choix faits que le monde est
merveilleux et qu'on a une infinité de
possibilités mais dans tous les cas
c'est à vous de choisir
[Applaudissements]